Bueno de hecho a mí me parece que no hay
una reforma de fondo en primer lugar en
el nuevo índice de
de Estado de derecho México salió entre
los últimos lugares y creo que sin
estado de derecho este tipo de
situaciones van a seguir sucediendo
porque
dependemos demasiado de las fuerzas
armadas
estamos ya un año de terminar de
un periodo presidencial de seis años que
puso como como
señal propia de de del presidente López
Obrador a las fuerzas armadas por
delante sin que hubiese una policía que
atendiera este tipo de de de de de de
enfrentamientos digamos con el crimen
organizado la delincuencia organizada Y
pareciera que estuviera más fortalecida
que nunca Entonces estamos hablando
porque en esto último caso de un estado
fronterizo estamos hablando de un estado
muy importante porque tiene este muchos
kilómetros de vecindad con Estados
Unidos y lo que vimos en un video
recientemente me parece que es muy muy
complicado de describir en primer lugar
recientemente el presidente de la
república habla de una posibilidad de
una de una de ejecuciones fuera de la
ley pero es un video que de uno de de un
hecho que ocurrió el el pasado dieciocho
de mayo o sea estamos hablando de varios
días que ocurrió Esto entonces aquí hay
una serie de cuestiones implicadas en
todo esto y que que refleja la la la
vulnerabilidad de las instituciones del
estado mexicano ahora decía por ejemplo
el presidente López Obrador que tiene
que castigarse a los responsables por
este hecho y que hubo exceso de
violencia por parte de los uniformados
pero es el mismo presidente que dice que
por convicción humanista No puede haber
mano dura contra los grupos criminales
qué lectura se puede hacer de estas
declaraciones
Pues es que esa es la contradicción y lo
único que estamos viendo en el video es
una serie de faltas
a digamos el estado de derecho al al a
los procedimientos judiciales y como
usted bien recuerda el presidente mismo
por un lado no no ejerce un impulso
importante en en fortalecer los la la
las ejecuciones digamos los procesos
judiciales por otro lado lado le da toda
la la el respaldo a las fuerzas armadas
para que creen en la guardia nacional
que en todo caso sería Tendría que haber
sido la primer respondiente en una en
una persecución como la que vimos en el
video no estaba la guardia nacional
estaba el ejército y
por otro lado tenemos a una a una
autoridad Federal no no solamente local
digo ya no digamos local no estamos
hablando de que en el video vemos a los
a los militares sacando Estas armas tipo
Barret de un alto calibre y y esto ya
nos habla de una ya una un poder de
fuego que ya no lo van a atender las
policías locales Entonces sí me parece
que tiene razón cómo es posible que que
no se no se haya dado una una un mensaje
más vertical de autoridad por parte del
presidente de la